hi there steve kaufman here today i want
to talk about learning chinese or
mandarin chinese versus
japanese and korean remember if you
enjoy these videos please subscribe
click on the bell to get notifications
so
uh i have learned
two varying degrees of fluency
mandarin chinese which is the first one
i learned back in 1968
full time at school but living in an
environment which was not mandarin
speaking in other words hong kong
uh then i learned japanese
basically on my own
uh helped by the fact that i could read
chinese characters and of course living
in japan for nine years my japanese got
progressively better and then i said at
some point i think in the early 80s i
should learn korean because i have
invested so much time in learning uh
chinese and japanese but i never had
much time for it
and at different sort of
points i have
given it a go three months here six
months there
and i'm really not very satisfied with
the level that i have achieved
in korean but let's compare these three
languages
so they're
east asian languages from a geographic
point of view because
these three countries are located in
east asia however they are not of the
same language family chinese is sino
tibetan so
related to languages in tibet burma
i don't know all of them i'm not a
linguist in the sense of being you know
someone who studies linguistics
of course japanese
according to some is related to the sort
of
ural altaic languages korean
turkish mongolian there are other people
who challenge that but it's a completely
different language family
both of them korean and japanese
um
but
the underpinning of japanese and chinese
in terms of vocabulary is chinese
uh in the case of japanese even their
writing system their phonetic writing
system
derives from chinese characters so china
had a major influence on them of course
learning these languages has become
easier than ever i learned chinese and
japanese at a time when there was no
internet there were no mp3 files there
was no way no online dictionaries you
certainly couldn't do the things we do
at link import stuff from
newspapers from
youtube from
netflix
or
you know
basically save words to a database for
later review and all of these things
weren't available you had a book you
looked things up in a dictionary and if
you had the money you got yourself a
teacher and if you were lucky enough to
live where the language was spoken as i
did for japanese
then of course you took advantage
another thing i learned languages
because i'm interested in history
and so it's important to understand that
what we talk about today as china korea
japan
and in the case of china at one point
whatever four or five
billion people
uh japan maybe 125 127 million people
uh korea would be 50 plus
25 i don't know the exact number for
north korea 75 million people those are
large language groups and as i said
chinese insofar as vocabulary is
concerned
is the base
more than half of all of the
words used in chinese and japanese
especially in more serious content much
as is the case in english where much of
our more sort of serious
okay academic
vocabulary comes from french
in the case of japanese and korean comes
from chinese so geographically we
consider east asia as an area we look at
china but it's important to remember
that
you know
homo sapiens came out of africa spread
all over the world
moved eastward towards
asia
maybe to some extent increasingly people
feel there was some
you know intermingling with uh previous
um
call it homo sapiens like we are homo
sapiens sepians so
you know neanderthal or the equivalent
in asia might have
had its bit of contribution i just don't
know
but it's possible because things they
said were not the case before it turns
out they do more research and they
discover for example that uh many human
or homo sapiens sapiens did mix with
neanderthals
um at any rate so you if you look at a
map of human movements 50 000 years ago
you see people moving through china
moving from the north down to the south
uh even the ainu supposedly
sort of indigenous to the to japan they
came over from the mainland
uh
there's no one indigenous to japan they
didn't spring out of the ground like
mushrooms they came from somewhere they
might have come by a
sea route and there are theories that
people went to japan via shanghai
originated in southern china or that
they came across the korean peninsula
this is 2 000 years ago
so at some point things sort of
solidified and there is the sense that
at least in terms of
you know
genetics not that that matters
but
japanese with their ainu
sort of admixture
and the koreans and the mongolians and
the manchurians
uh
they're in the northern chinese they're
sort of one group tibetans even though
the chinese and the tibetans are closer
linguistically
and then the southern chinese southeast
asians that's sort of like somewhat
different group with a lot of
scrambling going on and of course
historically a lot of those peoples in
central or in in inner asia call it
mongolians and the kitans and the
tanguts and the the manchus and the jur
george heads or george henson they were
quite powerful in their own right and at
various times conquered their neighbors
and so lots went on before we ended up
with what we got today
so just a little i i like that kind of
stuff and so then of course uh over the
last few thousand years these countries
have developed distinctive you know
histories of their own and they
developed a language of their own each
one of them and a writing system of
their own and in the case of chinese the
writing system is exclusively
pictograms each
character represents meaning
not always identifiable in terms of sort
of
pictorial or or image wise although you
can with explanation see how it's
derived from something that
we could visualize
but mostly it's it's an idea so it's an
ideogram
i guess that's the way to describe it
and most of those ideograms have uh a
phonetic component
uh and that's where
the
the kana that's used in japanese in
japanese they have these ideograms but
they also have two parallel phonetic
scripts
which
derive from
certain chinese characters which were
used to represent sounds in japanese and
then eventually evolved into
kana the and this happened about
you know 900
a.d or so
uh
part of that whole range of influence
that came over from china
uh
artistic religious literary and so forth
uh in the case of korea somewhere around
the 15th century supposedly their king
created hangul
which is uh a phonetic writing system
that started from scratch and has no
influence from chinese characters
so that's insofar as the writing system
is concerned
um
it's the first uh you know the the uh
romanization or the phonetic you know
writing system that we cannot use
to get a sense of how these words are
pronounced when we don't yet know hangul
or we don't yet know hiragana
the chinese use pinyin
which was developed uh you know
after 1949 it replaced previous systems
that had been created by by foreigners
personally i thought the yale
romanization system was better because
in pinyin they use letters like q
and x
in ways that we aren't used to so
q has a ch
sound
because theoretically the cheer in
chinese is a little different from cho
so they got a different symbol similarly
the x is a she
she which is different from s is kind of
between sha and s so use an x so if you
get a name card from a chinese person
and they've got cues and x's in there
you'll be quite confused until you get
used to it but once you get used to it
it's actually quite a practical system
the japanese use a romanization system
there's two they're seeing the one that
is
the most helpful
is one where you know if you have a word
like hachimitsu which is um
honey
then the hachi chi is ch
and mitsu tu is tsu
however in the
japanese writing system in in hiragana
or katakana
because you have sort of
sets of these syllables these are
syllables so you have sets of katki
kukeko
and then it goes
uh ta
that uses the t sound t a ta
so
in the japanese system the t becomes a
chi and it's so they they decide that
therefore for the poor foreigner trying
to pronounce the word hachimitsu we
should write it to be pure
h-a-t-i-m-i-t-u hatimitu which might be
you know
close to the the japanese system but is
useless for
a non-japanese speaker trying to figure
out how to pronounce
a japanese word
fortunately that's not used too much
except by the purists
now in korean they have a romanization
system which i find the least useful
because it uses the letter e in all
kinds of different ways and i'm never
clear whether this is a some kind of a
diphthong
or an attempt to
to
represent you know
none
i never know quite what it's trying to
do and sometimes it seems to have a
a y uh role
whenever i see the the uh
korean uh romanization i just ignore it
i
if i'm reading on the internet i'll use
text-to-speech
or i'll use the hangul
so it's really not very helpful but
again developed by you know the ministry
of education so a whole bunch of very
serious people came up with this thing
as somehow being
i don't know close to the original
korean so that's so far as the writing
system and the
uh call it transliteration of
romanization systems used in any case i
think you have to listen you can't rely
on
the romanization you have to get
yourself used to seeing
something written with their phonetic
script which doesn't exist in chinese
and then how it's pronounced and if you
do enough listening you gradually get
used to it in the case of all three
so that's we've covered the writing
systems the differences the romanization
differences
um pronunciation obviously the biggest
problem in chinese
is the tones
and there are no tones in japanese or
korean because remember japanese and
korean belong to a different
language family
so tonal languages thai you know
vietnamese
tibetan i guess i'm assuming casino
tibetan whatever
but japanese and
and korean are not total
so to get the tones i found it very
difficult to try to remember the
individual tones
um
with your reading if you're reading a
link the tones are marked a lot of
places they will give you marks you know
ah
so they'll show you what tone it is and
by the end of reading a lot in pinyin
with the tone marks you gradually start
to get used to it but the bigger thing
is do a lot of listening focus on
phrases so that these natural phrases
come out with the natural tones and and
recognize that you're going to start out
at 30 accuracy move to 40 50 60 70
you'll never be 100 but you'll get
closer and closer
so tone is not a problem in japanese
however there are people who claim that
there is this
pitch tone issue in japanese i have
i wasn't even aware of it when i lived
in japan
nobody has trouble understanding me
i don't think it's an important issue
unless you are some kind of a purist
that you want to you know
be a hundred percent like a native but
then the issue becomes which pitch tone
are you going to copy because the pitch
seems to me quite different in osaka
than it is in sendai or in tokyo so i
think it's more important to pick up on
and this is true for all languages pick
up on the natural intonation the natural
rhythm
of the language try not to introduce for
example english intonation into japanese
or korean
watashi wa
they don't say that i'll touch you it's
a little more monotonous more like
french and you have to catch
you know you get a hold of that
intonation
by the end of doing a lot of listening
without trying to worry about is this
sound which pitch and stuff at least for
me
not something i spend any time on i
would far rather increase my vocabulary
increase my comprehension and in doing
so i will increase my ability to
communicate effectively
uh
korean i found that the pronunciation
actually is quite similar to uh to
japanese of course the words are
different in fact some words sound the
same and are completely different
from japanese but i find this the
pronunciation is if you can pronounce
the one you can pronounce the other
and in terms of european languages
you know greek spanish any of these
languages where you have few diphthongs
basically pure vowels it's going to be
similar to those two languages
okay grammar
generally speaking having studied slavic
languages romance languages german
i find the asian language is more
forgiving when it comes to grammar
it's harder to make a mistake
they're more flexible i go today i go
tomorrow i go yesterday
uh
not quite but almost
in japanese there is a clearer sort of
indication and in korean
uh of tents not so much in chinese uh no
gender
no number
um
yeah it's it's it's easier
uh
this is somewhat compensated
or at least the the counterpart to that
is that the different levels of
politeness
uh
what the
linguistic students call register you
know is quite a bit
more differentiated than say in english
or in european languages
so you have to be a little careful
i therefore try to keep it neutral in
japanese and korean don't wander too far
down the sort of casual side of things
and i don't go too far into the very
formal
polite kind of thing stay neutral until
you get very good at it and then you'll
have a sense of what what form of a word
verb or whatever is appropriate less of
a problem in chinese
normally they're not as polite or as
formalized as the japanese and the
koreans
now another issue when learning a
language is the availability of content
and
to that extent i was very lucky when i
studied mandarin chinese
because the yale and china series had
had such a broad range of material
beginner material
you know
books on geography history with 500
characters 1 000 characters
uh a range of of reading material with
glossaries behind every chapter or every
page
on literature history you name it
[Music]
communist propaganda whatever it might
be
it was complete
i did not find that to be the case with
japanese i had to regularly scour the
bookstores to find
any kind of reading material with with
the glossary
uh
of course easier today because you can
you can find content
you can go to these automatic
transcription sites and get it
transcribed bring it into link for
example study it so it has become a lot
easier in that regard the same is but
even worse with korean one of the
reasons why i i would sort of go at
korean for a while and then stop is that
there is an abundance of beginner to
intermediate material in korean
uninteresting
uninspired
narrators
very difficult to listen to
a lot of emphasis on
you know older sister younger sister
second cousin uncle third and
all the sort of details of of different
words used for
relatives i don't have any korean
relatives
it to me
that's just
as part of this general trend in all
three languages
those people who create texts
the native speakers of those languages
put a lot of effort into you know
festivals and traditional foods and
things of that nature which
are therefore less familiar to us
and less difficult less more difficult
to get into at least as far as i'm
concerned i like to hear about how
people lead their everyday lives
and of course the voice is important it
has to have resonance you have to
connect with that voice
people natural conversations
uh about things in our daily lives often
you know natural conversations
subsequently transcribe this kind of
thing is is is much better but so
insofar as the accessibility and
availability of of learning material
uh better now
than before because of our ability to
connect to
netflix and and uh
youtube people who like korean drama or
japanese or chinese drama can find those
things to learn from so
just to
try to touch on some of the main areas
uh that influence people who are
studying these three languages they are
all worth it those are
important
centers of history of culture of people
that we want to get to know
they're all a little different they're
all well worth learning for their own
reasons
okay there you have it and i'm going to
leave
a couple of suggested videos one in
japanese one in korean or at least one
in chinese and one in
in japanese that you might want to
listen to
to get a sense
of those languages
okay bye for now